parce que le boujaer il est sous la main
il est soumis le chemin qui était déjà
plus bas qu'elle est appelée hier irrite
après cet éclat la ville continue il
s'ouvre et on arrivait à briand à peu
près williams appel à mort au fond
[Musique]
je n'ai plus que en grand sa queue on
attendrait longtemps prêté sommes pas
sûrs et ça m'amusait et puis j'aimais la
musique mais j'ai mes charges en tire
mais tout un discours qu'il a la chance
d'être bien des films chanter tout ça
lors après la guerre je vais retrouver
et puis on affrontait les sorties le
dimanche par exemple avec le plusieurs
copains en avant d'aller sillonner les
villages où il y avait des fêtes
et puis il y avait des fêtes on
s'arrêter et puis démarrer l'accordéon
que ça comme on s'amusait enchanté et
puis on est descendu adria leucate
village et a fait une gaffe et ballan il
ya des filles qui menait de l'ue pays à
côté du bourget de péage les petits
villages sont venues cette fille elle
invite danser et le disait un coquelet
mme l'épave du concorde cordeillan il
n'avait pas alors moi il ya le cope le
marché de la foire il avait une moto
jeudi deux requêtes sql d'en faire mal
et j'ai tourné ce qu'ils n'oublient
risques et c'est ce qu'on a fait on à me
ramener le taux du crédit zka les
branches il siffle faute de radio et on
a fait danser et c'est là que 18
j'ai vu hef faveur et puis je danse avec
elle et abreuvé j'avais 17 ans prévoit
l'avènement de cet effet du coup de
foudre
depuis deux jours à peine il ya parfois
du bonheur dans la peine
mais depuis qu'ils étaient amoureux leur
dire tel fut plus malheureux il vivait
avec son héritage et serait vite et plus
comme les gens je leur amour était un
vrai prétend aussi pu relever retard 20
ans c'est la romance de paris dans tous
les coins et fleurie et les poteaux aux
ordres eu un peu de rêve et de sciez
plus c'est dur friend of au bout par le
fis gentiment avoue que tout le monde
donne est épris fait la romance de paris
que tout le monde dans l'été prix c'est
la romance de paris
tu as vu un psy qui sentiments
[Musique]
j'étais content de retrouver une jolie
fille blonde on s'est mariés dont 47
avant le mariage il a fallu aller bétail
ravitaillement pour avoir de la farine
faire du pain blanc parce que ce n'est
pas du bon pain qu'on avait fait du
teint jaune c'est prier pendant la levée
oui alors le risque est souvent dans une
ferme était cultivateur et il est un
fils je crois oui qu'est il m'a donné du
doublé alors faible et on la bd chez le
jeune ibère chez le bon divers que le
moudre voilà c'est ça fait de la farine
ni bien sûr bien sûr elle dans la farine
on l'a mené aux boulangers qui était à
la rue du jura besson ne s'est pas
materis que les suppressions
voilà ils ont ri du pain alors ils m'ont
fait une fournée de pain la première
fois la guerre on a fait leur franchise
chez ta mère crie série comme des
sardines dans une veillée avec un peu ce
qu'il fallait
vive et où il y avait toute ma parenté
avec neuf ans bien tassés mais mon nom
que jules il y avait mon cousin notre
juin s'était marié avec sa copine la
musette de coeur lorsqu'à buvette et
blanches une cousine ma mère madame
cheval fut la pub lamerat victor a
choisi le principe je le déshabille dans
le jardin
mais qu'est ce que tu vas là-bas la tb
nos disques hors de portée
or qu'est-ce que cette idée encore
atteint voilà le tireur jeunes pop et
nonda casse était ressorti quant à lui à
mettre le disque mais voilà
la presse est unanime pour souligner le
stand al qardaoui d'un provocateur de
bowie de l'ong humanitaire puis un
expert de complicité dans dimanche
annonces de 80 % des françaises sont
entre parenthèses amoureuse comme ça
il existe garanx est un tueur un génie
maintenant d'aller voir les films que
j'ai faits en 1945
oui ce curé mouaraki m'a prêté une
petite caméra avec des petits films de
10,10 m alors j'ai commencé avec ça tout
de suite je suis les enfants à moirans
je fais les filles de gp les roches du
quart et j'ai pris la pancarte de noir 1
je suis montée fut la place et c'est là
que j'ai commencé à filmer les gens mon
cousin
et puis les gens que je connais fait
quoi
la petite jeanne est sortie de la messe
on voit michel billaut vois je cite les
noms qu'on voit marcel vincent perriot
loulou sur du café clovis moyen qui est
encore vivant maintenant garçons
coquelin bonnier magna clovis marieville
broc la voilà c'était sur la place à
chacun du premier film
[Musique]
et
arrivée d'une nouvelle perturbation par
l'ouest avec de la pluie du vent de
l'aquitaine la bretagne elle
progresserait ensuite vers neige comme
cet après midi elle s'étendra des
pyrénées à la frontière belge mais
israël s'est calé sur les gens de l'est
l'isolait seulement dans le midi les
températures de 7 à 15 degrés et 10 à
marcq et est un grand merci à vous tous
auditeurs de rtl qui est toujours plus
nombreux à nous écouter
elle que nous ne sommes plus que jamais
la première radio
elle part elle pas évident parce que je
ne peux pas y revenir
on avait pris la mer pendant quelque 2,3
après l'étalé sur la place pasteur
s'étaient envolés théâtre et chants de
marins on a tout sous la main
même quand elle peut rien oui je vous
paierai décacheté jeunes à le porter
penser c'est un lit mais il ya du monde
sur tout le temps dit vendredi qu'il y
avait la musique elle avait conservé
yeux un peu partout la place pas mal
d'enfants
oui il ya un mois il ya eu l'époque mais
je leur dis que tu es bien maintenant
comme le dimanche on voit pas pendant la
dernière personne ne sait ce qui ménage
et par se faire détruire
selon me
[Musique]
tt grand bonheur très fort et de bonheur
c'est tout perdu ça malgré des
restrictions qu'on allait pas comme
maintenant mais en face on était quand
même été une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oui
[Musique]
là encore les films
et
car j'ai commencé à filmer en 1945 il ya
eu des mauvais il m'a dit mais faudrait
voir madaschi barrio il y a triomphé des
films en 1930 avant midi ben faudrait
que la bière en parler à sa petite bande
à même de tous les épines
elle va mêler film c'était le barrio
avait fait j'ai géré 8 et souvent non
parce que c'était tout en mêlée quoi
alors j'y vais et j'ai repris un fils de
1930 pour niveau en 1938
voilà
un combat
et villages où là
alors on va voir les corps
je connais tous les défauts rue jetté
refuge de priory c'est pour stocker
moyens pas longtemps tels maurice louvre
ou le bas vers le haut mais yo jean
monneret botha bj en avril you le mono
core games
il y avait le feu n'est pas
[Musique]
ça c'est le tour du phare de fins au col
de la savine
c'est un tract aux filles il ya des
policiers et le duc
[Musique]
les pompiers de moulins 400 julienne
défendre un peu plus vite
voilà
depuis quand même
ou partie la place la mer des gamins de
moi
j'ai été aussi y avait 12 ans pour cette
petit bard les amarres
voilà mon instituteur qui est derrière
ce valeureux combi instituteur lui du
ciel ouvert la part bien vu barbier
des pompiers
cool
pour juillet sera fixée pour briller au
tambourin qu'avait parce que mon père
dépend lui aussi a connu huit sorties
madame andré miquel
en 1931 je rappelle qu'avec des chats je
lui ai dit les chats des filets d'un
mort à versailles pas encore ce moment
là si un jour j'en ai signé loire lors
de l'arrivée de la nuit
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
je
les plaignants qui à l'écran central par
endroits et puis là
[Musique]
le
et
m
[Musique]
j midi des plus innovantes 48
j'ai eu ma fille en retire des timbres
de faire 1 954 deviner si si elle se
confirme jean-claude un triangle de vie
[Musique]
elle
m
et
non
[Musique]
regardons
il était libellé jacqueline
coupe
alors qu'intel d'eau l'image n'est pas
couché la visite le dos
attends je vous lève un coup et puis
gris douala tapis en gir thème là et on
attend quelques secondes se faire
accorder
[Musique]
mais voilà les footballeurs ils sont
soyeux plein je laisse aux combats ils
vont sans peur et oliver elfira les
footballeurs qui se bagarrent
avec adresse mon garçon pour lons écoles
dans la voix
les trucs peur
[Musique]
l'organisation du sport en france sera
traitée sur le plan national par la
propagande en tous milieux et la
diffusion de la masse de méthodes de
technique et d'une mentalité sportive
les terrains existants seront d'abord
aménager en stable dans pleinement
convenant à la fois à l'éducation
physique et au sport de compétition
un de nos premiers soucis sera donc d'
intensifier la diffusion du sport et de
l'idée sportive donné à tous les moyens
d'améliorer leur santé et à certains
ceux de développer au maximum leur
attitude pour leur permettre d'accroître
leur nom sportif de notre pays
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs la
direction de radio circus là vous
présente ce soir un numéro unique au
monde
la fil de fériste mazères l'anus
m
marcel le tueur je soutiens banques us
qui n'est rien de plus beau
[Musique]
la ville de félice de la piste
affairistes d'uranium accuse intel
une très grande artiste le fildefériste
a dû radio circulent
notre des foires mam cents us
ma mémoire radio circus
[Musique]
e
auj
[Musique]
oh
le chef de l'état est entraînante avec
sa mère je suis passé tout est annoncé
partout en garde n'empêchera les choses
de se faire comme la france a voulu
quelques papes
il est alors moi j'avais ma caméra et
j'ai bien lu 9 et 10 chalets j'ai
commencé à filmer cas si larry était
debout
il était debout sur ses lotos qui
l'amenait jeu les filles mais qu'at-il
fait quand il a peur des foules mais
libre aux jo général jusqu'en
différentes couleurs pour elle même pour
pouvoir assurer sa mission qui est celle
de l'établissement de la paix la liberté
l'égalité et la fraternité
[Musique]
ah ah
oui contre 4
[Musique]
alors fait un effet
à balad eu lim achetés à des sans abri
est on arrivé là bas on était les
casques rouges étaient vouloir des 80
quoique le café des remous y avait une
terrasse
ah oui et puis ils débarquent dans cette
aventure intéressante et les sens il
fait vibrer des baux il faisait des
bonds pas d'étrons défendez manger à ma
prière souvent
[Musique]
m
des vautours garni est mêmes arômes fido
des revient là qui est dit une année le
pai
il avoue
et ça s'amuser là bas aussi je ne suis
pas là vient shanxi la chambre chartis
est la perte d'habitat les bienvenus
voilà l'heure
[Musique]
ah la la
le
la la
m
dire que ces terres me semble et
vieillot aujourd'hui il me semble
nouveau
et puis surtout il y avait moi et moi
ces deux mots ne vieillissent pas
souviens toi tu as parlé de la picardie
et des roses qu'on trouve la barre tholy
deux amoureux nous avons dansé sur les
roses de ce temps là
[Musique]
c'était joli c'est valérie une épopée de
cette jolie rivière nam est clair que
nous devons traiter au nom non
[Musique]
j'ai visité dans les voiles et moi je me
vois la batterie par un on a vécu là bas
c'est d'amendé tout est important je
vais là bas et ça m'est resté exactement
comme jj oui j'ai pas besoin des films
pour nom pourra leur fournir de bria moi
mon père comme si c'était un trois
contre un
tout tout tout tout au nom de ces
derniers s'étaient écouter village est
formidable c'est pas qu'on avait tous
parce qu'avant le primeur passé on avait
quand même une école on avait une
fromagerie paix avait une petite
épicerie on était vraiment bien et bien
peut pas dire et puis d'ailleurs tu sais
mais qui travaillait à 30 ans il est
d'attendre il à l'elysée où il y avait
des tourneurs après tout il y avait des
tourneurs et puis les cultivateurs aussi
[Musique]
résultat 50 tonnes d'acier sont dans le
cours de l'un dans quelques mois elles
seront submergés par la mise en eau du
barrage de vouglans avec une retenue
d'eau longue de 35 km ce barrage de
vouglans qui vient d'être mise en haut
d'un mur de 550 mille mètres cubes de
béton et ils barrent la rivière d'ain
encore une retenue de plus de 600
millions de mètres cubes qui vont
permettre de produire un événement 235
millions de kilowattheures dont le pays
a tant besoin
pkoi ray
mais là
tu vois à l'infini dopage tu sais pas
sourire mais c'est quand y sont
apparents num qu'ils ont fait sauter le
pas on a dit c'est toi c'est fichu
c'était en 1968
mon père était moyen atteint 7 1 138 qui
a permis de faire mémoire 50 hier deux
jours après le mariage de william
oui oui bonjour a tous mal la logan mais
ben saada singer
ici nous envisageons de réaliser une
plage publique nous aurons parkin il y
aura un lotissement touristique avec des
chalets nous comptons d'ailleurs
fermement rassurer un avenir touristique
et certains autres communes
c'est comme ça
lt fait pas là encore
voilà
antolin lives bon petit viser la barre
et le meuble d'horloge de nos loges
la ville va toile est un registre il a
ça va je suis
[Musique]
non
mais
[Musique]
j'attends
augmenter l'effet plomb et j'avais une
versailles que j'avais acheté c'était à
sa tante et sa fille en 61 il a fallu
s'arrêter aux as
c'est en train de chauffer cockney et l
italie avec un vicari il connaît faire
voeu a repris voilà on a d'abord été la
grande statue donc dans de don carlo
enfin charles de bodrum et on a monté le
dans le monumental du colossal
je ne connais pas un on a connu des
cousines c'était pas mal d'ailleurs les
biens de la famille ou annaba puis après
les camps là qu'après l'état naturel
[Musique]
dallas climat s'ouvre
comment
[Musique]
donc
qui tue
qui veut nous
ils sont
[Musique]
com
noir de donchery
zhu
concert
c
utilisez vous
dans l'édito
non
[Musique]
ap
c'est tout
ou bien pas
oh
begin
aujourd'hui
là
créer maçonnerie
m
pour
[Musique]
c'est sûr
non
[Musique]
c'était au koweït et au sénat oui
c'était à lyon ça beau nier mais là
charbonnier à charbonnières oui j'avais
fait comment on appelle ça le séminaire
à vie avec leur vie ravi qu'on peut
l'être et viennent alors ont du talent
il a bien mangé bien sûr j'étais le
savez nous on marche sur ce marché avec
la la femme de cet âge ta victoire et
ont marché dans l'allée où il y avait
des roses autour a déclaré l'époque la
ville ça puis on sert nico si au final
les premiers postes la télévision
transformera votre vie grâce à la
télévision sans quitter votre fauteuil
vous pourrez assister deux chez vous à
tous vos spectacles préférés
vous devez avoir chez vous un appareil
de télévision
[Musique]
théâtre variétés musique voyage
actualité match concrétise sur ce
parcours
ne vous en veut plus dire
[Musique]
lui voyez les a faits à première vue un
clash qui l'avait mois il a touché cas
toujours géré il continue quand il a
décrété ne pas faire quelque chose parce
que c'est décrypter ses parfums densité
je connais il a beaucoup de qualités
parce que c'est de ce côté-là de métier
qu'il a fait savoir après ça peut
reconnaître que c'était quand même
laminé tête pour connaître
[Musique]
d'ailleurs on parle
depuis
le tour
autour d'eux
[Musique]
dans la boue
eh eh bien
[Musique]
j'étais un des leurs
et nous aimerions arriver par l'énergie
mais que ce qui a été accompli si des
manches et qu'elles ont à nouveau très
serré
c'était fini mobile en [__]
[Musique]
il veut pas
ouais
[Musique]
mais bon
je vaux
saurait
alors vite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais mieux mais toujours
ouais
[Musique]
où
m
l'achat
le
mon que le champ
et je sais que ton coeur lâche un aussi
souviens toi mon séjour merveilleux
septembre
pour que les seuls
humblement et
la chanson je ne
non
c'est rigolo dans le coeur
ils oublient que la vie a vraiment
comment fait pas fait jour de fête tombe
le vin d'un
redonner la chanson
des bons non
[Musique]
[Musique]